E aí
[Música]
não existe uma outra forma de Fronteira
esta muito mais Sutil muitas vezes
imperceptível viu mas que vez ou outra é
revelado por algum acontecimento aqui
nos marca Afinal a vida é isso os
acontecimentos os nossos movimentos E
por que não a nossa relação com as
próprias Barreiras você já deve ter
percebido que a fronteira com me refiro
é a do coração aquela que nos impede de
enxergar o outro como ele é de nos
conectar e aprender com próximo ao longo
da minha vida eu tive a oportunidade de
viajar para muitos lugares inusitados
e participando como médico em missões
humanitárias
visitem lugares marcados por miséria
fome guerras
e por mês meu contato com as histórias e
culturas desses povos
percebi que esses lugares estão bem são
marcados por sorrisos risadas esperanças
a pena que poucos têm oportunidade
perceber isso também
em Jericó uma região montanhosa e Rural
do Metal a 2 mil e 700 metros de
altitude
aprendi que existem formas diferentes
além de contar a passagem do tempo neste
exato momento já se passaram
2078 anos no calendário
e já que esse nosso estranhamento Faça
as contas e para o Nepal tenho 113 anos
fico feliz aparentemente estou bem
conservado para cidade naquela região
montanhosa
deparei-me com uma menina no colo da mãe
é quase uma pluma junto no e-mail
respirando o que podia e Era pouco a
criança estava gravemente acometido por
sepse Neonatal
infecção generalizada logo fui na minha
posição de Médicos Sem Fronteiras
iniciar o tratamento
proposto intubação soro antibióticos
equipamentos estava tentando tudo que
podia para manter o coração daquela
criança batendo
foi quando Foi interrompido pela família
Doutor na Master obrigado em minha
palestra mas não queremos isso tudo uma
única Pergunta a mim pela mãe posso
amamentar minha filha
eu não tive resposta sabia que a criança
não tinha forças para sugar o que eu não
entendia é que o que ambos queriam
compartilhar por mais alguns momentos
era o calor entre mãe e filha
e aqueles minutos segurando a sua filha
poderiam significar uma eternidade na
memória daquela mãe é
existem mesmo formas diferentes de
contar a passagem do tempo
o doutor
deixemos a nossa filha partir
aquela mãe
transformou angústia em cuidado e
coragem e tomou a filho no seio mesmo
sabendo que não iria fluir Luiz
propriamente leite mais vida isso ela
sabia e tentou me ensinar
aquela mãe queria sentir pela última vez
a sensação de segurar seu filho no colo
deixar que sua filha levasse uma marca
do seu amor aqui não era mais importante
para ela do que qualquer recurso que a
medicina poderia oferecer principalmente
Porque de fato eu não tinha recursos
para salvar a criança
e a mãe sabia disso eu
médico com fronteiras não naquele dia eu
fui embora chocado pode os molhados
impotente frente as fronteiras que a
vida me impôs havia fronteiras muito
duras em novembro de 2014 viajei para a
faixa de gaza na Palestina
alguns meses antes o exército israelense
havia iniciado a sua retirada da região
encerrando a principal incursão no
território e somente nesse processo
entre 700 e oitocentos palestinos teriam
sido mortos
quando anunciei os amigos e colegas que
este era o destino da minha próxima
missão quase todos acreditaram que eu
estava me dirigindo para uma terra
arrasada em meu último dia na missão uma
criança com menos de 2 anos de idade
havia sido atingida por uma bomba
incendiária
imediatamente levado ao setor de
emergência no hospital ar chifre em casa
E era uma queimadura extensa e profunda
que atinge a toda a sua face suas
palavras foram destruídas E com isso não
podia fechar os olhos escalos assim suas
córneas não eram lubrificados os olhos e
de um se ressecar e não haveria como
preservar sua visão
partimos então para reconstrução das
pálpebras uma delicada e complexa
cirurgia
o Opera vamos sobre recente alerta de
possível bombardeio nas redondezas do
hospital
diante dessa ameaça ouvir por um tempo a
instalação Pânico entre a equipe médica
a cirurgia estaria comprometida e a
criança condenado a cegueira
com firmeza e sobre a função de líder de
equipe procurei acalmar o grupo de
profissionais
que já se preparavam para abandonar o
hospital
Eu exijo me firmeza
o que não lhe era exigida fora do
contexto de guerra
eu aprendi naquele momento
eu quero ouvir tal que eu fizesse
voltamos a cirurgia e concluímos o
planejado com enxertos e outros recursos
a criança agora tinha seus olhos
protegidos
Poderia abrir os e fechados
a escapar da cegueira que certamente
viria sai do hospital com alma leve não
me importava com as ameaças
algo surpreendente
voltei ao Brasil com sentimento
inexplicável deixando aquele ser
familiares EA Palestina mais feliz eu
não posso negar encontrei sim muito
sofrimento mas Encontrei muitas outras
coisas além disso também
superei algumas de mim fronteiras ao
descobrir que a Palestina é um lugar de
pessoas como qualquer outro no mundo mas
parece que somente pisando lá para nos
darmos conta disso
havia realmente muito o que eu podia
fazer de bom lá mas foi um lugar que fez
muito bem a mim também
eu descobri que os palestinos têm
ferimentos como todos os nossos no corpo
ou na alma Em ambos
há mais ou menos graves mais sempre
sentidos no corpo Realmente são
peculiares ferimentos de guerra
e estes eu estava a tratar com
celebridade conforme aprendi com meus
Mestres pais e mães na medicina e
cirurgia e apoiado pela longa e sólida
experiência de Médicos Sem Fronteiras o
uso da alma são sempre peculiares E aí e
faço estamos todos sempre em momentos de
solidão solenes para estes o tratamento
é mais difícil em gás vejo outra vi um
breve período de 20 minutos de
cessar-fogo a cidade fantasma se
transformava paz brincando com seus
filhos amigos se abraçando casamento
acontecendo a Selene tocava estão se
recolhiam dos bombardeios
já haviam vivido 20 minutos
ali também a passagem do tempo para
contada de forma diferente em todas
essas viagens e experiências
algo restou bastante Claro para mim
existe muita coisa que não nos contam
sobre os lugares devastados do mundo não
nos conta o que quem vive nesses lugares
continuam sendo pessoas
de corpo e alma que os adultos ainda
protegem suas crianças e que essas por
sua vez ainda sorriem com sorvete gelado
em dias de sol quente não nos contam
sobre os sonhos que são esquecidos ou
não e nem das pequenas belezas em meio a
tantas dificuldades
é o quê sofrer é universal também não
não são Médicos Sem Fronteiras
aceito de bom grado com toda minha
energia
especialmente aquela amorosa de ser um
médico e antes ainda ser uma pessoa um
ser humano
lidar com os limites que são inerentes à
vida de todos os nossos é um grande
desafio
perdoe o cheiro de arrogância em assim
considerar como O Grande Desafio claro
que fala o que a partir de mim mas
confesso quero provocar esse incômodo em
todo mundo para mim como um médico para
nós envolvidos diretamente no
atendimento
àqueles que no momento mais frágil de
sua existência nos procuram ou são
achados por nós esse limite ganha um
corpo duro no balanço vida e morte
um acordo com dados publicados pela he
he is what as autoridades do Ra mas
mantiveram cerca de
1885 palestinos detidos em 2019 já em
2021 mais de 212 palestinos foram mortos
entre confrontos com ss de Israel no
Nepal foram cerca de oito mil 199 mortes
e
17.867 feridos após os terremotos sem
chave cor compartilhe esses dados para
alertá-los que na próxima vez em que
encontrarem notícias sobre o sofrimento
das regiões supostamente arrasados do
nosso mundo
se você se tentem também transpor as
suas próprias fronteiras
para enxergar esses países apenas pelo
seu sofrimento
e se recorde de que falamos de pessoas
pessoas como nós com seus próprios
sorrisos sonhos e amores e que aprendam
assim como eu aprendi que a vida insiste
além das fronteiras e
E aí